that's crazy man so for you like cuz for
people who don't know you do you're very
secluded where you are um when you say
Gravedigger Mountain like we're
literally there's a mountain you have a
mountain it's your Mountain but for you
like secluding yourself even more is
interesting just getting a house boat
getting a yacht hey if you want to see
me these are my coordinates pull up on a
helicopter we ain't
talking I told my wife then last night
she asked me how about eat fish I say
fish she said you can eat fish all day
yeah you can I said I get I get some
food ship to me I guess yeah you would
have to somebody would have to bat it to
you but that's not I mean I don't think
that's uh
unrealistic are you are you like um hey
you could tell that I smoke like no no
smoke coming this part of right no I can
tell yeah for sure this the first time
you smoked in this part of the house man
actually when I was looking for the my
clothes looking for this suit earlier
man I walked out the [__] Studio
smoking a cigarette and I had to keep
that door
open how long have you smoked I've been
smoking cigarette since I 7 years old
damn my dad was like that my dad tells
everybody I've been smoking since I was
eight you want me to give this [__] up
my dad got arrested when he was nine I
think my um he tried to burn down his
house my god dad I think he was I think
this [__] ran away from the arm man but
he can't you know how you get a home
pass I guess yeah and that [__]
ran away to New York New Orleans cuz he
want to go back so I guess during the
time like as he was at the house I used
to be watching that [__] smoking
cigarettes and every time he throw that
[__] out go grab it you grab it you and
you smoke what was left yeah
damn yeah I did at one time my dad threw
a cigarette down I was probably like
seven and I remember I picked that [__]
up I took a hit and I th I was coughing
so much I threw up and my mom was like
see that's what the [__] you get picking
up a [__] cigarette and ever since
then I was I was out on it